mais si ce n'est pas rentré à la maison
écoutez je suis sûr qu'il va revenir son
prénom jamal j am à elle parce qu'il est
un signe distinctif cicatrices tatouages
d'andorre le pseudo qu'on lui donne son
andru il a jamais eu de nom de rue il ya
eu un incident qu'est ce que ça signifie
toutes les informations devraient passer
par le lieutenant stoxx je ne connais
pas personnellement
on m'a dit qu'il avait reçu un message
lui demandant de devenir immédiatement
huit mois maintenant
elle passe de plus normal à une vrai
chien enragé
c'est bon que ça va bien se passer où
est notre fils
moi aussi j'étais enfant hockey est ce
que vos enfants sont noirs
je demande pas aux gardes tes mains sur
le volant mon garçon regarde droit
devant et ne fait aucun geste brusque il
ne faudrait surtout pas rendre l'homme
aux gilets pare-balles nerveux quand il
s'approche de sa vitre et qu'il te
pointes directement un glock sur ta
tempe
c'est quand même toi qui a disparu de sa
vie dans ça va être ma faut que tu es
parti tu l'a abandonné retrouvons vite
notre fils et repartons chacun de notre
côté d'accor table écoutez moi nous
avons attendu et on a été patient ça
suffit de nous prendre pour des cons ou
et jamal en ce moment je veux savoir
on veut lui parler tout ce qui
je voudrais savoir ce que vous attendez
de moi s'il vous plaît retrouvé mon fils
[Musique]